estamos en bihar en el noreste de la
india la región con la mayor tasa de
fertilidad del país
cuya débil es una trabajadora social
desde hace diez años anima a las mujeres
de su barrio a tener menos hijos y su
trabajo está empezando a dar frutos hace
diez años una mujer de esta zona rural y
pobre tenía en promedio más de cuatro
hijos mientras que ahora tienen tres
es tan lindo ahora que tuviste tu primer
hijo quieres tener más vale no no por
ahora puedes usar preservativos o la
píldora siempre y cuando funciona yo
hago
gallega si tienes que ser cuidadosa te
traeré todo eso y te lo explicaré luego
podrás utilizar estos métodos espera al
menos tres años para tener tu segundo
hijo
hasta entonces cuida de ti y de tu hijo
aquí como en el resto del país son las
mujeres las que asumen la
responsabilidad de la planificación
familiar
y es mejor tener una familia más pequeña
nos permite educar mejor a nuestros
hijos y enviarlos a mejores escuelas
podemos alimentarlos bien una familia
grande es más complicada es un tormento
para ayudar a estas mujeres a tener
menos hijos cuya sugiere un método
radical e irreversible la ligadura de
trompas te recomiendo ligarse las
trompas una operación si incluso los
hombres pueden operarse no sólo las
mujeres valen
qué buen chiste apenas pueden ver su
propia sangre le hacen reír
dile a tu marido que si no te deja
operar te que lo haga él la vasectomía
es más fácil indicar
si alguien debe hacerlo ya sé que tendré
que hacerlo
no gana lo suficiente para criar a
muchos niños y con la inflación las
familias empiezan a darse cuenta de que
les conviene tener sólo dos hijos y
centrarse en su educación para
asegurarles un futuro los niños deben
ser capaces de independizarse para no
convertirse en una carga para los padres
y plano de américa más llévame banda me
va a gustar a marisa más llévame amerita
más llévame bailar baute a abc banda
natal hasta hombre no se vale nada
en la india más de un tercio de las
mujeres casadas en edad fértil optan por
la ligadura de trompas una operación
irreversible que dista mucho de ser
aceptada universalmente en un país en el
que el control de la natalidad era
sinónimo de esterilización forzada en
los años 70 pero hoy en día muchas
mujeres utilizan este método
anticonceptivo para librarse de
embarazos no deseados al pana de 38 años
y su cuñada rada de 26 tuvieron su
primer hijo a los 16 años
me casé a los 15 años y a los 20 ya
tenían tres hijos nos casamos muy
jóvenes y tuvimos hijos demasiado pronto
nuestro cuerpo y nuestra salud sufren
por eso hoy en día
por eso decidí operarme quiero poder
educar a mi hija y centrarme en su
futuro es actuar la prueba por ende no
quiero que tenga la misma vida que yo
ella se merece algo mejor la inmune de
las últimas generaciones de mujeres
indias con nuevas aspiraciones parecen
contribuir a un mejor control
demográfica
al que está laica
ahora las mujeres se casan cada vez más
tarde a los 26 28 incluso a los 30 años
solo quieren uno o dos hijos y cada vez
tienen más voz pronto no tendrán que
recurrir a la ligadura de trompas
aunque el descenso de la tasa de
fecundidad en la india refleja el
progreso de la sociedad las altas tasas
de ligadura de trompas revelan la falta
de información sobre otros métodos
anticonceptivos
el orden menguar o muchas mujeres que se
hacen ligar las trompas probablemente lo
hacen pensando que tuvieron muchos hijos
y que este método es de una vez por
todas por así decirlo
en realidad estas mujeres carecen de
conocimientos sobre las posibilidades y
usos de otros anticonceptivos el
gobierno también anima a sus
trabajadores sociales a convencer a las
mujeres para que se sometan a la
ligadura de trompas muchas de estas
mujeres no toman una decisión informada
según un estudio publicado hace unas
semanas la tasa de fertilidad de la
india descendió por primera vez a dos
hijos por mujer por debajo del nivel de
reemplazo generacional quizás este sea
el inicio de mejores condiciones de vida
en un país donde más de 200 millones de
personas viven por debajo del umbral de
la pobreza